we are at spring preserve in las vegas
do not know what to expect they just
told me it's a hundred
acres
of land and on this land i've seen that
there's museums there's a butterfly
exhibit i'm excited this guy's excited
let's get started
go monkey go go go monkey show em what
you got monkey yeah yeah yeah let's go
monkey let's go monkey
were you shy
okay so first up we're gonna watch a dog
show and all of these dogs are rescued
dogs did you know that that they rescue
them and they teach them how to do
tricks and they're only having two shows
today this is the first one i can't wait
to see what they do
you excited
yeah and we're gonna get a one more
frisbee right here come on let's make
some noise guys
what's up guys
[Music]
a little spin around action good job all
right
bran spanking you to the show all right
so here we go buddy what are you gonna
do right here come on buddy watch out
you got a good job all right
now this is the truck come on get
[Music]
well he's our brand new rescue and if
anybody has a border collie you
understand
if you guys are real if you guys are
here one energy guys
[Applause]
[Music]
say hi
okay go
you see it wasn't that high
we are in the butterfly exhibit grandma
would love this
look at that beautiful blue one
where is it oh it's right here
look at that one
do you like butterflies yeah they'll
come to you if they want to come to you
they'll come to you
but you just have to
no it's
no she's just getting
some sunshine
right now taika and i are inside the
butterfly exhibit
and i'm a little bit nervous because i
don't understand i mean i know that tyga
doesn't understand how delicate these
beautiful butterflies are but i have to
show you they have some blue ones
they have some
uh yellow ones they're so beautiful okay
okay enough about my face look at these
butterflies look at this
wow
what's that
yeah they love a lot of
sweet stuff and fruity stuff
no i didn't want to get on your hand
to go yeah they're probably scared
so tyka's still drenched so that's his
butt sticking out of the house right
[Music]
so um
i'm just letting him play now so he can
get air dried
he had so much fun getting wet this
place is super cool we've only seen
three things the doggy show the
butterfly exhibit
and this water thing and it's so cool i
think i think we might get a membership
again a hundred acres
also not spawns
it just seems really cool for families
and i'm just here under this tree
in some shade finally because it's
80 something degrees
we are
back home
took a shower taika you so clean clean
taika
you so clean clean
uh oh no is your back okay
i think he just killed spider-man
is playing some toys well i'm playing
with
clothes i'm folding it this is actually
the second load of clothing that i've
done i like to separate my clothes with
uh from dark like mediums to lights and
then whites go
oh you killed them again huh
on a killing spree i see and that was
different oh okay
got it
this tends to be my sunday night routine
um wake up in the morning try to do
something cuny with tyka and papa and
then
um
we just start doing chores papa right
now is in california
um but
the show must go on here so i clean out
my fridge did i do that yet i don't
think i did that yet
i think i did that i did that actually
yesterday
um clean out my fridge get everything
restocked
so that's either me going to the grocery
store or ow my instacart some stuff
just so i'm all set up for my week
um
what else am i doing oh just ordered
dinner
usually i like to make dinner but
today i go out i wanted pasta
and usually i like eating it's almost
coming in
yes i like adding protein to my pasta
um
and all my protein sources were frozen
so
i'm gonna order some pasta
hello
continue folding
what are we gonna have after pasta
monkey
um ice cream oh i can't wait to show you
what kind of ice cream tucker got don't
say anything i know you're going to give
it away
my hand looks crazy but stay tuned
dinner has arrived but we've already
been eating it oh my god so this place i
don't even know what it's called it's
the war i'm the worst but i was able to
create my own pasta so i created this
guy
it is roasted garlics broccolini olive
oil
chicken breast
bomb but this guy didn't like it
he likes this one and it's like a
creamy sauce chicken mushroom
limey concoction
you like it
oh my dear lord
and it came with some complimentary
bread
oh jesus
this guy's been into percussion
there you go
he's been into so much music these days
good job judy
all right this is where we cut it
okay so while tycho wraps up dinner i
want to talk about the ice cream so we
have this local spot
out here in vagus i know there's a
couple in the u.s um
i had never heard of this before moving
to vegas
but
yes handles
been around since 1945
and i was just kind of reading the story
back here miss alice handel she used to
make um
homemade ice cream and she would use
fresh fruit and just the greatest finest
ingredients it says the fresh fruit came
from our garden isn't that cute as hell
okay so these are the popular flavors
graham central station which is graham
cracker chocolate and there's actual
pieces of graham cracker in it and it is
so
bomb dig a day
okay
yep bomb dig a day
oh jesus that was disgusting and this
one's called
blue
monster
that's blue
blue
monster according to this one's called
the blue dab monster because he loves
this song by eiffel 69.
and this one is obviously blue the blue
has nothing to do with the flavor other
than
i think she was trying to talk about
cookie monster because it has oreo bits
as you can see there and chocolate chip
bits oh chocolate cookie
bits i should say and chocolate chips as
you can see it there big ass lump
yeah so these are the flavors i have yet
to try anything from handles that i did
not like i've had like banana cream
um i can't remember the flavors i've had
but i've ordered a ton and they've all
killed
and they're super soft look at this
i can't wait to dive into this
i knew it
i knew it
wait what
was he about to do
baby what is he watching on youtube
oh my god that mouth
definitely bart's kid
speaking of the devil what time do you
think it is to get home huh
it's like 9 30
p.m it's not too late
that's true yeah wait for all the ladies
to go back home first
what ladies
ladies i train with goddamn look at all
those wrinkles dude
oh my god
well welcome back home you took a one
day trip did you tell your dad
no
yeah he was like wondering where you
were and i'm like i don't know how to
explain this to you bro what did you say
yeah well i was like he went to calif
and i went to california
and my dad started to see walking in his
uh it is yeah
thank you
yeah he busted them out skinny and he
was see you walking yeah no i didn't
tell him
yeah he was wondering yeah i mean
i guess if
you'll figure it out i mean yeah that's
how dudes communicate you know
like if i go downstairs and he's not in
his room i'm like oh he left okay yeah
yeah
there's a kidney yeah well you missed a
really candy day of me and taika time i
saw the pictures that was really cute
yeah and i so he kept saying during the
dog section the dog trick section he
kept turning around and goes hey that's
emma
and i was like thinking
i was thinking some other student right
and i looked i'm like that's not anyone
dude yeah and then we went to a sec like
that area that thing was over we went to
a different area
um throughout the day yeah and then he
saw that person again and he goes no
look you see it is emma and i'm like oh
i introduced myself to the mom and the
mom was really cool we just ended up
like following them the whole time
oh cool yeah so we made friends with
parents and they're super cutie yeah and
then taika and emma just kept holding
hands everywhere they were like best
pills
those skinny pies yeah
the hell are you holding your own feet
you weird guy why
this pewdiepie
yeah you missed a really kidney day
today i know i saw the picture that was
super cutie how was your day
good uh
shot a bunch of new barbecue talk shows
nice with jp which is really cool he's a
highly uh
sought after guy that everyone wanted us
to collab with
and then he ran me and signed the mic
through a pretty sick like bodybuilding
session
which is really good because he's really
smart so he'll talk about like
muscle and shirt insertions and shoes
like movement patterns that go with the
fibers of the mouth like really smart
stuff you know so stuff i'm on that
level i've never trained at before
so like
i didn't use that much weight and my
back is freaking pumped
nice so is yours did he did he pump your
stomach too because he's been kind of
pumped for a few months
uh
he didn't but i do have a secret weapon
which is sick
what is it eating whatever you want no
so you know how we're dropping the
barbecue get lean program
we're dropping it very soon we're
dropping it very soon i'm gonna run it
and uh we're writing a 12-week youtube
series on it uh-huh and in that youtube
series it's you versus me on who can
lose the most weight
yeah well i win oh the most well i don't
even have that much to lose that's not
fair
you have a ton to lose like
so much to lose no body fat
percentage-wise
right yeah my secret weapon
is jp is gonna do my diet programming
that ain't fair
so i guess that's not fair
that's not fair
your homegirls will do yours then
all right i am going to grab some of my
friends uh
to do it then i can get jp dears dude
he's super excited he feels like he
can't wait to see like what i look like
underneath all of this marshmallow we
all can't wait dude
even spider-man back there has been just
waiting collecting dust
he's jacked
oh you did your job
thank you [ __ ] off
all right on that note [ __ ]
you
hell yeah not you what
i'm gonna have sex
i'm on my period so
anyway
mexicans love dipping stuff in chamois
is real that mexicans love dipping all
kinds of stuff into more so that's the
stuff you like yeah but i'm the mexican
one i know you're the one that you're
the one that's eating the chamoy and
you're the one with your boy yeah
exactly so why i still that didn't work
i love chamoy i don't
yeah but you're saying mexicans yeah i
ain't dipping in anything you don't need
to
you don't make any sense i'm the
chopstick you're the boy and we're about
to have a baby but you said mexicans of
the chamois
i'm not eating
no you're trying to make it can you just
stop playing with your goddamn feet
already
okay anyway on that note thank you so
much had a wonderful day hope uh you
felt some of that in your heart
and you have a beautiful day
and i'll see you tomorrow
you're an itchy bastard